DEFENSE DEPARTMENT BANNED
DOMESTIC TRAVEL FOR MEMBERS OF
THE MILITARY.
ERIN AFTER ORTY IS AT LAX.
>> Reporter: WE’RE STANDING IN
INTERNATIONAL ARRIVALS AT LAX,
YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK BEHIND ME,
WE’RE SEEING PERIOD YOU CAN
ARRIVALS OF GROUPS OF PEEK IF
THAT HAVE JUST TRAVELED BACK.
AMERICANS WHO HAVE RETURNED FROM
EUROPE IN THE PAST 14 DAYS ARE
BEING FUNNELED THROUGH 13
DIFFERENT ARMIES INCLUDING --
AIRPORTS INCLUDING HERE AT LAX.
THEY’RE ASKED A SERIES OF HEALTH
QUESTIONS, ALSO GIVEN DETAILS
ABOUT THE CORONAVIRUS, ANY
PRECOUGHS THEY NEED TO TAKE,
SYMPTOMS TO LOOK OUT FOR.
THEN THEY’RE SENT ON WITH A
DIRECTIVE TO GO AHEAD AND
SELF-QUARANTINE ON THEIR OWN FOR
A COUPLE OF WEEKS.
NOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP SPOKE ABOUT
THE TRAVEL BAN ON FRIDAY DURING
HIS EMERGENCY DECLARATION.
OF COURSE, NOW THE EUROPEAN BAN
INCLUDES THE U.K. AND IRELAND
AND POTENTIALLY COULD INCLUDE
DOMESTIC AIR TRAVEL AS WELL.
>> SPECIFICALLY FROM CERTAIN
AREAS, YES, WE ARE.
AND WE’RE WORKING WITH THE
STATES, AND WE ARE CONSIDERING
OTHER RESTRICTIONS, YES.
>> Reporter: NOW HERE AT THE
TOM BRADLEY TERMINAL AT LAX, THE
TERMINAL BEING THE SECOND
LARGEST INTERNATIONAL TERMINAL
IN THE FUNNELS SOME 4.8 MILLION
PEOPLE THROUGH HERE A YEAR.
WHAT WE’VE SEEN SO FAR TODAY IS
A LOT OF EMPTY AREAS, AND THAT’S
USUALLY SOMETHING YOU JUST DON’T
SEE HERE.
WE’VE ALSO SEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
TAKING PRECAUTIONS.
YOU SEE PEOPLE WALKING BY WITH
MASKS ON.
WE’VE GOT A STATION BEHIND US
WITH HAND SANITIZER, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE ARE JUST DOING THE BEST
THEY CAN AND TRYING TO GET HOME.
WE TALKED TO ONE PERSON WHO TOLD
US ABOUT THEIR PARTICULAR
EXPERIENCE EARLIER.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> DIDN’T WORRY ABOUT IT, YOU
KNOW?
>> IT’S LIKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
MESS.
EVERYBODY’S FREAKING OUT A
LITTLE BIT FOR, I GUESS, FEAR OF
THE UNKNOWN.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS HAPPENS
BEFORE.
AND I THINK WE’RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH.
SO JUST THINK POSITIVE AND THINK
THAT IT’S NOT GOING TO LAST
FOREVER.
>> Reporter: AND, ERIC, AGAIN,
EVERYTHING THAT WE’RE SEEING
HERE, A LOT OF PEOPLE TAKING
PRECAUTIONS.
I SAW A GENTLEMAN RIGHT NEXT TO
US PUTTING HIS MASK ON, AND HE
GAVE ME TWO THUMBS UP AND
SHRUGGED HIS SHOULDERS.
WE’LL BRING YOU MORE FROM THE
HERE AT THE LOS ANGELES
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT AS THESE
ARRIVALS COME IN THROUGHOUT THE
TODAY AND THE EVENING.
ERIC?
ERIC: GLAD YOU’VE GOT THE
SANITIZER --
>> Reporter: I DO.